nous avons tout de suite cette édition
par l'événement sportif la france est
bien championne du monde de handball
elle a su devancer l'équipe favorite la
tenante du titre la suède au terme d'un
match époustouflant et tout s'est joué
minute par minute tout au long de la
partie et jusqu'aux prolongations les
costauds menée par daniel costantini que
nous retrouverons en direct l'ont
emporté 28 à 25 et les grandeurs
d'euphorie dans les gradins à bercy avec
deux supporteurs de marque
inconditionnelle le président de la
république et le premier ministre
christophe portera à chaque fois les
mêmes scènes de joie d'émotion de
bonheur
l'air est bien connue des sports
collectifs français
les handballeurs l'ont interprété avec
brio une victoire qui doivent en grande
partie à leur entraîneur daniel
costantini et au capitaine jackson
richardson notamment contendant
heureusement a inventé ce [ __ ] c'est
vrai qu'on l'a tellement galéré avec gta
v sur qu'occupe la jamais eu de médaille
et la leaf est de remporter la plus
haute marche prend la médaille quand je
pense que ce ne sont pas bleus prononce
une victoire qui a mis du temps à se
dessiner même si en début de rencontre
les français semblent intouchables
les actions sont limpides défier doigts
ne parviennent pas à contrer les
inspirations française et à la mi temps
les bleus mènent 11 à 10 dans les
tribunes on commence à y croire mais en
deuxième période les siennois champion
du monde en titre retrouve un peu de
leur superbe
les deux équipes mort sont alors très
proches l'une de l'autre dans les
dernières secondes du match messi loi
prenne davantage à 20 secondes de la fin
22 21 dernières tirent dernière chance
pour les bleus d'égaliser 22 22 il faut
jouer les prolongations
sous le regard de spécialiste les
français plus frais plus volontaire puis
les terminer s'impose finalement sur le
score de 28 à 25
cela vaut bien les félicitations du
président
un superbe exploit un très beau match
nous sommes deux retraits heureux et
c'était le plus beau cadeau que cette
merveilleuse équipe pourrait faire à
daniel constantini et de ça aussi nous
sommes heureux je crois que sortir son
meilleur en bal en finale contre les
suédois et à bercy pour être champion du
monde ça doit être le rêve pour tout
s'est équipée pour naturellement pour
que daniel constantini donc je suis très
heureux pour leur entraîneur pour le
public de bercy pour leur plus grand
bonheur
les français ont remporté leur
championnat du monde six ans après les
barjots on découvre les costauds